Wenn ich einen Film zum Thema Angst
realisiere, heisst das auch,
sich den eigenen Ängsten zu stellen.
Mir wird's schnell zu eng,
zu laut, zu viel.
Im Gedränge fühle ich mich unwohl,
möchte weg.
Aber ich habe keine Panikattacken
wie viele Menschen,
die unter Angststörung leiden,
einer psychischen Erkrankung.
Oft ohne erkennbaren Auslöser
werden sie von Ängsten befallen.
Sie erleben diese als einen Sog,
aus dem sie kaum mehr herauskommen.
Es ist jetzt ungefähr 30 Jahre her.
Es war zur Anfangszeit
meiner Angststörung,
als ich wahnsinnig viel
vermied und verdrängte.
Ich hatte Angst,
mich diesen Situationen zu stellen.
Ich fuhr damals oft Zürich - Bern.
Ich machte dort für drei Monate
eine Weiterbildung.
Jedes Mal drehte ich fast durch.
Ich musste aufstehen
und auf die Toilette gehen.
Ich begann zu hyperventilieren.
Ich hatte Angst,
mir würde etwas passieren.
Dass ich im Zug wäre,
und mir niemand helfen könnte.
Ich fuhr nur Bummelzüge.
Der Grund ist klar:
Ich hätte jederzeit
die Möglichkeit gehabt,
aussteigen zu können.
Ich trieb es dann sogar
auf die Spitze.
Ich schrieb mir jeweils auf,
wie lange der Zug
von hier nach dort brauchte,
also bis zur nächsten Station.
Ich war total auf Nadeln
und total angespannt.
Wenn ich dann im Bahnhof einfuhr,
dachte ich: "Super."
Dann ging es weiter.
Ich stieg nie aus.
Diese Zuggeschichte
hat sich wirklich hartnäckig ...
Sie hat sich über die letzten
25 Jahre wirklich gehalten.
Dass ich das heute ohne Probleme ...
... ziemlich ohne Probleme kann,
ist jetzt seit vier Jahren so.
Das kann man auch
später flexibel einsetzen,
aber gerade diejenigen,
die im 90°-Winkel sitzen,
und wenn dort die Wand
auf die andere Wand stösst ...
Es gibt dann einfach
ein paar Wandelemente,
die man nicht beliebig
und flexibel einsetzen kann.
Marcel Meier ist ein erfolgreicher
Projektleiter und Verkäufer
in der Möbel- und
Einrichtungsbranche.
Als ich ihn kennenlernte,
wäre ich nie auf die Idee gekommen,
dass er schon jahrzehntelang
unter einer Angststörung leidet -
seit seiner Jugend.
Doch seine Krankheit wurde lange
nicht richtig erkannt und behandelt.
Marcel Meier
hat es irgendwie durchgestanden.
Ich habe mir eingebildet,
dass diese Störung
aus meinen Lebensumständen heraus
entstanden ist.
Ich hatte eine depressive Phase,
ich hatte wenig Geld,
bezahlte viele Alimente, konnte am
sozialen Leben nicht so teilnehmen.
Der Job hat mich, wenn man so will,
am Leben erhalten,
und dort hatte ich
meine sozialen Kontakte.
Ich hatte auch eine Phase,
in der ich recht viel allein war.
Ich igelte mich dann ein und betrieb
eine Vogel-Strauss-Politik.
Mein damaliges Rezept
im Gegensatz zu heute war,
wegschieben,
wegschieben, wegschieben,
verdrängen, verdrängen, verdrängen!
Das machte es
natürlich nicht besser.
Ich weiss gar nicht,
wie ich das durchgestanden habe.
Wahrscheinlich hat es
mit einem Urvertrauen zu tun.
Ich wusste eigentlich immer,
dass für mich die Sonne
wieder einmal scheinen würde.
Ich hatte offensichtlich die Kraft
und Energie, nebst der Arbeit,
dass ich das auf irgendeine
Art und Weise einfach ...
... überstanden habe.
* Dumpfe Geräusche,
Rauschen einer Flugzeugdüse *
Wie für jeden anderen Menschen auch
gehören Ängste
zu meinem Leben als Filmemacher.
Je älter ich werde,
desto ängstlicher werde ich.
Eine allgemeine Ängstlichkeit,
die sich nur manchmal
konkret festmachen lässt.
Früher konnte ich problemlos
in der ganzen Welt herumreisen,
heute fällt mir
ein grösserer Ortswechsel schwer.
Sobald ich meinen Alltagstrott
aufgeben muss, werde ich unsicher.
* Rufe, Aufprallen eines Balls *
Conny Grossenbacher führt
seit acht Jahren mit ihrem Mann Kurt
ein Restaurant
auf einem grossen Sportplatz.
Vor 17 Jahren
erlitt sie ihre erste Panikattacke.
Schau mal.
- (Mann) Ist schon gut.
Danke sehr. Merci.
Bei Ausbruch ihrer Angstkrise
betrieben sie noch
das schöne Quartierrestaurant Blume.
Eine aufreibende Arbeit,
deshalb gaben sie später
die Blume auf.
Weisst du noch?
Manchmal,
nach einem anstrengenden Sonntag,
sassen wir hier draussen
an einem Holztisch ...
Mhm. - ... im Dunkeln,
und schauten nach drüben.
Alle Lichter gelöscht.
- In aller Ruhe was getrunken.
Im November 2000
hatte Kurt einen Herzinfarkt,
als ich für vier Tage
mit meinen Jass-Frauen
nach Istanbul gefahren war.
Die Nachricht
erreichte mich morgens um 3 Uhr,
als wir ins Hotel zurückkamen,
auf der Combox meines Handys.
Ich musste dann
überstürzt nach Hause fahren.
Meine Angst war, dass ich ihn
nicht mehr lebendig antreffen würde.
Er hat das zum Glück überlebt,
aber für mich
war es ein grosses Trauma.
Im nächsten Frühling
fingen die Panikattacken an.
Ich konnte das gar nicht zuordnen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
es wäre etwas Körperliches.
Ich konnte mir nicht helfen.
Ich konnte auch nicht mehr
unter die Leute gehen.
D.h.,
ich konnte nicht mehr arbeiten.
Ich hatte Angst,
dass ich unten im Restaurant
vor allen Leuten zusammenbrechen
und sterben würde.
Das Schlimmste war, dass ich
bei jedem Atemzug das Gefühl hatte,
das wäre nun der letzte.
Für mich war das
etwas vollkommen Ungewohntes.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass mir so etwas passieren könnte,
weil ich mit beiden Beinen
auf dem Boden stehe.
Ich bin bodenständig aufgewachsen.
Ich habe Leute, die psychische
Probleme haben, fast belächelt.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass man das
doch selber lösen können sollte.
Die würden einfach
ein wenig übertreiben.
Dann hat es mich selbst erwischt.
Ich stellte mir vor, wenn man mich
am Morgen tot finden würde,
hätte man ja keine Ahnung,
was passiert war.
Deshalb schrieb ich mal auf,
wie es mir
in diesen Momenten ergangen ist.
Ich schrieb ...
... z.B.: "Zeit."
Es war etwa 3.15 Uhr in der Nacht.
Ich mass meinen Puls.
Normalwert, also etwas hoch: 85.
Blutdruck ideal: 130 zu 77.
Nachher die Symptome, die ich hatte:
Herzrasen, ein Stechen links,
Atemnot und Schwindel.
Und ein komisches Kribbeln
in den Fingern,
ein Taubheitsgefühl in den Fingern.
Das schrieb ich auf
und legte den Block neben das Bett.
Ich konnte dann einschlafen,
weil ich dachte,
dann wüssten sie vielleicht,
woran es lag,
dass ich jetzt gestorben war.
Dann, ein paar Tage später,
hat es mich zum ersten Mal
tagsüber erwischt -
an einem Sonntagmittag,
während des Mittagservice.
Kurt kochte in der Küche, ich wäre
eigentlich am Büffet gewesen.
Wir hatten eine Serviertochter.
Es war nicht übertrieben viel los.
Wir hatten schon zu tun,
waren aber nicht gestresst.
Und plötzlich ging es wieder los.
Ich sei dann auch immer
ganz bleich geworden.
Ich ging zu Kurt in die Küche,
und er fragte: "Was ist los?"
Ich sagte: "Es geht wieder los,
ich habe es wieder."
Er holte mir einen Stuhl,
und ich konnte mich
bei ihm an den Herd setzen.
Er rief dann der Serviertochter zu,
sie solle den Krankenwagen rufen.
Die waren dann schnell hier
und hängten mich im Krankenwagen
an das mobile EKG an.
Sie fanden wieder nichts.
Für die definitive Abklärung
brachten sie mich
aber noch ins Waidspital.
Dort wieder dasselbe:
EKG, alles ohne Befund.
Ein etwas erhöhter Puls.
Und wieder Beruhigungstabletten
und nach Hause geschickt.
Danach schwor ich mir:
"Ich gehe nicht mehr ins Spital,
wenn so etwas ist."
Kommst du nicht zum Abendessen?
- Achtung, heiss!
Zu welcher Zeit?
- Ich glaube, um 18 Uhr.
Claudia Moser hat zwei Kinder -
Lela und Giulia.
Seit Langem
lebt sie ohne feste Beziehung.
Bereits in ihrer Jugend
erlitt sie Panikattacken,
und es entwickelte sich
eine starke Angststörung.
Trotzdem
schaffte sie es immer wieder,
im pflegerischen Bereich
Arbeit zu finden
und die kleine Familie
allein durchzubringen.
Seit einem Jahr nun
bezieht sie nach langen Abklärungen
eine volle IV-Rente.
Am ersten Drehtag
sagte mir Claudia Moser,
dass sie in der letzten Woche
seit Langem wieder eine
akute Angststörung durchlebt hatte.
Ach, schau hier! Hier steht's.
Hier steht: "Parkplätze vorhanden."
Vor einer Woche bekam ich Schmerzen,
starke Schmerzen im Rücken.
Ich wusste nicht, was es war.
Ich machte mir immer mehr Sorgen,
und auch nach einem Arztbesuch
wusste man nicht, was es war.
Ich merkte,
wie mir die Kontrolle entglitt.
Meine Gedanken
kreisten immer mehr darum,
dass es etwas Schlimmes sein könnte.
Das jagte meine Angstsymptome
derart hoch,
wie ich es
schon lange nicht mehr hatte.
Ich kam dann nicht mehr
aus diesem Angstkreis heraus.
Ich konnte gar nicht mehr
rational denken.
Es drehte sich alles darum,
dass ich glaubte,
etwas wirklich Schlimmes zu haben,
etwas Gefährliches, etwas,
was mich auch umbringen könnte.
Trotz all der Sachen, die ich kenne
und die ich anwenden könnte -
gut durchatmen, mich beruhigen ...
Das ging alles nicht mehr.
Ich rief meine Therapeutin an -
täglich.
Sie wäre auch
zu mir nach Hause gekommen,
wenn es
noch schlimmer geworden wäre.
Sie half mir auch,
das muss ich sagen.
Und eine gute Freundin,
die selbst jahrzehntelang
unter Phobien gelitten hatte,
half mir auch sehr.
Das ist so die Grenze,
bis zu der ich gehen kann.
Es ist ... Ja.
Manchmal geht es etwas weiter,
manchmal geht es weniger weit.
Es kommt darauf an, wie es mir geht
und wie das Wetter ist.
Wenn es sehr heiss ist,
komme ich nicht so weit,
wenn es etwas kühler ist
oder wenn ich ein Fahrrad schiebe,
kann ich etwas weiter gehen, aber
sonst ist das hier meine Grenze.
Hier beginnt mein Herz zu klopfen.
Wenn ich weitergehen würde,
würde es immer schlimmer.
Allein auf dem Weg
mit einer Panikattacke
ist etwas vom Schlimmsten,
was ich mir vorstellen kann.
Was es genau ist
und wieso genau hier die Grenze ist,
kann ich nicht wirklich erklären.
Es ist einfach bedrohlich,
wenn ich weitergehe.
Weiter weg von allem,
was mir vertraut ist.
Mein Zuhause ist eigentlich
der einzig sichere Ort für mich.
Sessellift fahren, ist für
Marcel Meier beinahe unmöglich.
Nicht, weil er an Höhenangst leidet,
sondern weil er
keine Fluchtmöglichkeit hat.
Ich meide solche Fahrten über
schwindelerregende Abgründe auch.
Objektiv betrachtet
ist der Sessellift
eines der sichersten Transportmittel,
doch das nützt nichts,
wenn grosse Ängste im Spiel sind.
Andererseits sind Ängste
überlebensnotwendig und schützen uns.
Deshalb lernen wir schon als Kind,
Gefahren richtig einzuschätzen
und Ängste zu überwinden.
Ich hatte eine Monster-Panikattacke.
Eine sehr schwere ...
... wie ich sie
schon lange nicht mehr hatte.
Ich war im Büro,
ganz normal bei der Arbeit.
Es fing mit
einem körperlichen Unwohlsein an.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass ich
gleich vom Stuhl kippen würde.
Ich musste weg.
Ich musste aus dem Büro raus.
Zu der Zeit
war ich schon richtig am Rotieren.
Hyperventilation,
Engegefühl in der Brust,
und dann ergibt eins das andere.
Ich schaffte es dann mit dem Auto
noch knapp nach Hause.
Ich hatte wahnsinnige Angst.
Ich versuchte, mich hinzulegen.
Das ging nicht.
Ich tigerte in der Wohnung herum.
Ich brauchte eigentlich bis abends,
bis ich einigermassen ...
... wieder heruntergekommen war.
Dieser Schock sitzt mir immer noch
ein wenig im Nacken.
Dann kam das Wochenende.
Das ging einigermassen.
Weil die Panikattacke
im Büro stattgefunden hatte,
tat ich mich dann schwer daran,
am Montag ins Büro zu gehen.
Ich ging trotzdem,
merkte aber sofort,
dass ich mich nicht wohlfühlte.
Ich ging am Mittag
wieder nach Hause.
Sprich: Ich habe vermieden.
Das habe ich
die ganze letzte Woche so gemacht.
Ich habe
von zu Hause aus gearbeitet.
Therapeutisch
ist das natürlich falsch,
aber ich habe es
irgendwie nicht geschafft.
Ich habe die ganze letzte Woche
daran gekaut.
Ich bin immer noch angeschlagen,
wenn man so will.
Ich merke es jetzt auch,
wenn ich darüber rede.
Es ist mir
richtig, richtig heftig eingefahren.
Ja, ich hatte wirklich Angst,
dass ich sterben würde.
Obwohl ich ...
Es ist so schwierig. Ich versuche,
es jetzt zu beschreiben.
Wenn man so richtig durchdreht ...
Es gibt keinen wirklichen Ausgang.
Ich habe das noch nie geschafft.
Es gibt wie nie:
"Ich drücke jetzt auf Stopp
und trete aus dem Teufelskreis."
Das gelingt mir nicht.
Es gelingt mir auch nicht ...
... in dieser Alarmstimmung.
Da leuchten ...
Da schrillen alle Alarmglocken.
Es gelingt mir dann nicht, mir
über den Intellekt gut zuzureden:
"Du hast es ja schon
einige Male gehabt,
und es ist nichts Schlimmes."
Das ist jedes Mal ...
Ich habe verteilt
über die letzten 30 Jahre,
ich weiss nicht,
mind. 200-300 Panikattacken gehabt,
und ich sollte es langsam wissen.
Das nützt einen Dreck.
Flugangst
ist ein weit verbreitetes Phänomen.
Ich habe Angst vor einem Absturz und
beruhige mich, indem ich mir sage,
dass Flugzeuge zu den sichersten
Transportmitteln gehören.
Flucht ist eine häufige Reaktion
bei Angststörungen.
Für Conny Grossenbacher
ist das Schlimme im Flieger
das Ausgeliefertsein,
keine Kontrolle zu haben.
Das wäre anders,
wenn sie selbst die Pilotin wäre.
Wir durften für eine Hochzeit
einen Apero machen,
im Kirchgemeindesaal
hinten über der Blume.
Ich hätte dort
eigentlich auch helfen sollen -
Gläser füllen
und Apero verteilen und so.
Aber Kurt musste das allein machen.
Ich war nicht in der Lage,
zu helfen.
Ich hatte nachts
wieder eine Attacke gehabt,
und schlief dann lange.
Ich war danach einfach
vollkommen fertig.
Man konnte mich so
bei der Arbeit nicht brauchen.
Dann machte er den Apero allein.
Zwei meiner Freundinnen
waren zu dieser Hochzeit eingeladen.
Als sie ihn allein antrafen,
fragten sie nach mir - was los sei.
Er erzählte es ihnen.
Die eine war eine gute Freundin
von meinem späteren Psychiater.
Die andere
hatte selbst Panikattacken erlebt.
Beide wussten sofort,
was es sein könnte.
Sie gaben Kurt die Telefonnummer
dieses Psychiaters.
Ich solle ihn unbedingt anrufen.
Da habe ich zum ersten Mal gehört,
dass das Ganze
wirklich eine Krankheit ist,
dass es das wirklich gibt, dass
diese Symptome typisch dafür sind
und dass ich nicht allein bin -
und v.a., dass man mir helfen kann.
Und was am Anfang
auch noch sehr wichtig war:
Er schickte mich zu einem Arzt,
um das abklären zu lassen.
D.h., ich war in einem Labor,
um mir Blut abnehmen zu lassen.
Dort untersuchten sie
gewisse Sachen,
die es hätten sein können.
Dann war ich noch
bei einem Herzspezialisten,
um einen Herz-Ultraschall
machen zu lassen.
Das war sehr wichtig für mich,
um das Körperliche
definitiv ausschliessen zu können,
dass es etwas Ernsthaftes ist.
Das gab mir
auch eine gewisse Sicherheit.
Und natürlich die Gesprächstherapie.
Ich ging erst
dreimal in der Woche zum Psychiater,
jeweils für eine Stunde.
Ich erzählte dann einfach.
Zu diesen Gesprächstherapien habe
ich noch Antidepressiva bekommen.
Und für Notfälle Temesta,
zur Beruhigung,
wenn es ganz schlimm geworden wäre.
Das musste ich aber gar nie nehmen.
Mir reichte es schon,
es zu Hause zu haben
und zu wissen, dass ich
darauf zurückgreifen kann,
wenn ich es nicht mehr aushalte.
Das ist für mich
eine Möglichkeit, zu entspannen,
weil ich mich
im Rücken so verkrampfe,
wenn ich diese Attacken habe.
Es nimmt mir fast den Atem.
Ich merke, es ist so eng
im Brustkorb oder im Oberkörper.
Bei mir ist es jetzt
v.a. in den Schultern.
Das kann sie mir lösen.
So kann ich nachher
wieder freier atmen.
Dadurch habe ich dann
auch weniger Angst.
* Langsame, elektronische Klänge *
Ich gehe nie an grosse Festanlässe.
Einem Gedränge weiche ich aus.
Im Kino sitze ich am Rand.
Mittendrin kann ich es aushalten,
doch ich vermeide es, wenn möglich.
Claudia Moser hingegen
geht nie ins Kino -
auch nicht an andere
öffentliche Veranstaltungen.
Das Auto ist für mich
seit sehr langer Zeit
der einzige Ort
ausser meiner Wohnung,
der mir vertraut ist.
Hier fühle ich mich sicher,
hier habe ich das Gefühl,
dass mir nichts passieren kann.
Es ist ein Zufluchtsort.
Mein ganzer Alltag
steht und fällt mit diesem Auto.
Ohne Auto wäre ich
auf 100 % Hilfe angewiesen.
Ich könnte nicht einkaufen, ich
könnte keine Arztbesuche wahrnehmen.
Ich könnte die Kinder
nirgends hinfahren.
Ich hätte
keine sozialen Kontakte ausser Haus.
Ja, es ist für mich wie eine ...
Ja, wie Heimat, wie ein ...
Ein Ort, wo ich aufgehoben bin
und der mir Sicherheit gibt.
Claudia Moser muss mit dem Auto
möglichst nahe heranfahren können.
So kann sie in kleinen Läden,
die ihr vertraut sind, einkaufen.
Der Parkplatz muss
unmittelbar vor dem Geschäft liegen.
Ähm ...
Die kleinen.
Die Cherrytomaten?
- Ah, genau.
In einem grossen oder einem kleinen?
- In einem grossen.
Es ist jetzt schon eine Weile her,
dass ich nicht mehr arbeite,
also dass ich
eine volle Rente bekomme.
Das ist bald ein Jahr.
In der ersten Zeit
brauchte ich es wirklich sehr,
einfach mal
nicht mehr arbeiten zu müssen.
Der ganze Druck fiel weg.
Es tat mir am Anfang wirklich gut,
dass ich merkte,
dass ich weniger leisten musste.
Die ganze Belastung, die ich neben
den Ängsten vorher noch hatte -
wie Kinder grossziehen,
finanzielle Probleme, Beziehung ...
Das alles ist weggefallen.
Ich bin Single,
und ich bin zufrieden damit.
Meine Kinder werden älter und
brauchen mich nicht mehr so sehr.
Arbeit habe ich keine mehr.
Was bleibt,
bin ich mit meinen Ängsten.
Das ist wahrscheinlich,
was ich momentan spüre.
Ich war vorher nie so nah dran.
Klar musste ich damit leben, aber
ich hatte immer genug Ablenkung.
30 Jahre lang.
Ich besuche mit Marcel Meier
das Sanatorium Kilchberg,
eine psychiatrische Klinik.
Dort wurde er vor zehn Jahren
mit einer akuten Angststörung
sechs Monate lang
stationär behandelt.
20 Jahre
nach seiner ersten Panikattacke
bekam er hier endlich
eine klare Diagnose,
einen Namen für seine Krankheit
und ein für Angstpatienten
bewährtes Therapieangebot.
Mir ging es damals
wahnsinnig schlecht.
Ich hatte auch
eine Arbeitsplatzsituation,
die sehr schwierig war.
Ich war quasi ...
Ich wusste noch knapp,
wie ich mein Passwort
am Bildschirm eingeben musste.
Im Verlauf des Morgens
packte ich dann mein Köfferchen,
ging aus dem Büro raus
und kehrte nie mehr zurück.
Dann entschloss ich mich,
in eine Klinik zu gehen. Ja.
Es ging einfach nicht mehr.
Ich war fix und fertig.
Richtig fertig.
Ich habe sehr gute Erinnerungen
an diesen Ort.
Ich verbinde es ja nicht mit ...
Ich verbinde es nicht per se damit,
dass es mir damals
grausam schlecht ging,
sondern
es war eigentlich der Start ...
Man kann es wohl schon so sagen:
Es war der Start in
ein wieder selbstbestimmtes Leben.
Ich übernahm das Steuer wieder.
Davor war ich jahrelang oder
jahrzehntelang fast nur Passagier.
Ich redete damals
1 Std. lang mit dem Oberarzt.
Er schrieb und schrieb
und schrieb und schrieb.
Ganz am Ende -
wir hatten keine 5 Min. mehr -
sagte ich ihm, ich hätte
übrigens manchmal Panikattacken.
Der legte sofort alles weg.
Er hörte sofort auf zu Schreiben.
Er sagte, er habe mir gern
1 Std. lang zugehört,
aber 5 Min. hätten gereicht.
Das Wichtigste
hätte ich am Ende gesagt.
Man nenne das so und so,
so könne man es therapieren,
diese Möglichkeiten gebe es.
Das war eine Erleichterung,
auch wenn es danach
extrem hart wurde.
In der Klinik musste sich Marcel
Meier zuerst einem harten Entzug
von einem süchtig machenden
Beruhigungsmittel unterziehen.
Dieser dauerte einige Wochen.
Erst danach konnte man mit
der Expositionstherapie beginnen.
Unter Begleitung einer Fachperson,
der Psychologin Karin Hammerfald,
konfrontierte sich Marcel Meier
mit Situationen,
die bei ihm Ängste auslösen.
Beispielsweise musste er einen Weg
unter freiem Himmel zurücklegen.
Mit der Zeit lernte er so,
sich seinen Ängsten zu stellen
und sie schrittweise abzubauen.
Ich kann mich erinnern,
dass ich ein Papier erhielt -
das hatten wir vorbesprochen -,
auf dem stand,
ich solle probieren, mich zu
konfrontieren oder zu exponieren.
Auf keinen Fall verdrängen.
Auf mich hören, Angst eins bis zehn.
Habe ich überhaupt Angst?
Wenn ja, wie hoch ist sie?
Wird sie, während ich mich exponiere
und gehe ... Steigt sie dann?
Wie fühle ich mich?
Also wirklich
die konkrete Auseinandersetzung
und nicht: "Ich muss jetzt
möglichst an etwas anderes denken,
damit ich das überhaupt überstehe."
So habe ich das in Erinnerung.
Genau, sondern eher im Gegenteil:
Wenn Sie merken,
dass Sie gedanklich abdriften,
versuchen Sie wirklich,
zur Angst zurückzukehren.
Wie war es denn jetzt für Sie,
Herr Meier?
Easy.
- Anders als damals?
Ja, das ist inzwischen
wirklich Komfortzone.
Also ... fast Komfortzone.
Diese Situationen -
ob es jetzt hier im Feld ist
oder wenn ich
in einen Zug einsteige ...
Natürlich
ist es immer in meiner Erinnerung,
aber es ist sehr weit weg.
Und, äh ...
Das war jetzt
überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich kann mich natürlich erinnern,
wie es damals war.
Es war meine erste Exposition.
Das war definitiv
eine andere Baustelle.
Können Sie sich noch daran erinnern,
was die Ängste waren,
die Sie mit dem Feld verbanden?
- Ja, natürlich.
Natürlich, die Angst vor der Angst,
das Altbekannte.
Und tiefer liegend:
Wenn ich jetzt durchdrehe,
ist nicht in 10 m Distanz ein Haus,
in das ich mich flüchten könnte.
Also quasi keine Sicherheit ...
... auf einem weiten Feld.
Das machte mir extrem Mühe.
Ich kann mich erinnern,
als ich mal allein
auf dem Üetliberg unterwegs war,
und zwar wirklich allein,
lief ich in eine Panikattacke rein.
Das war wahrscheinlich auch
der Auslöser für nachher.
Man verbindet es ja immer mit
einem Erstkontakt oder Ersterlebnis.
Daran hatte ich schon zu beissen.
Für Fachleute sind die Auslöser
von Panikattacken meist erkennbar,
aber die tiefer liegenden Ursachen
dieser Erkrankung
liegen nach wie vor im Dunkeln.
Es gibt auch keine spezifischen
Medikamente gegen Angststörungen.
Angstlösende Antidepressiva
lindern zwar die Angst,
verhindern sie aber nicht.
Und Beruhigungsmittel,
Benzodiazepine,
lassen die Angst nur kurz
verschwinden und machen abhängig.
Medikamente
können sogar kontraproduktiv sein.
Es geht darum,
dass der Betroffene sich
mit seinen Ängsten auseinandersetzt
und lernt, mit ihnen umzugehen.
Finny, komm! Komm, Fuss!
Willst du kein Leckerchen?
Ja, dann nicht.
Bei der Arbeit war sie ein Ausfall -
nicht total, aber zu 70-80 %.
Sie wollte einfach
nicht mehr unter die Leute.
Es ist schwierig,
wenn man ein Restaurant hat
und die Chefin
nicht unter die Leute will.
Ich konnte nicht mehr.
- Ja, du konntest nicht mehr.
Das ist schon klar. Ich sage ja nur:
Von meiner Sicht aus
war es einfach sehr kurios.
Mein Hauptproblem
war v.a. am Anfang:
Ich konnte es nicht nachvollziehen -
überhaupt nicht.
Ich dachte:
"Verdammt, was ist denn los?"
Kann ja nicht sein, so etwas.
Das Problem ist v.a.:
Wenn man sich das Bein bricht,
oder sich in die Hand schneidet
oder was weiss ich,
da kann man helfen.
Da kann man was machen.
Aber hier kannst du als Partner gar
nichts machen. Verständnisvoll sein.
Manchmal nervt es dich auch,
immer verständnisvoll zu sein.
Das ist einfach so, auch wenn
du es dir nicht anmerken lässt.
Aber mehr kannst du nicht machen.
Ein ausgebildeter Arzt oder
Psychiater kann das schon fassen.
Aber ich kann es nicht fassen.
Für mich war es recht schwierig,
das Ganze überhaupt
verstehen zu können.
Das wäre für mich eben
wichtig gewesen. Dieses Verständnis.
Ich begreife das,
aber verstehen konnte ich es nicht.
Es ist ... Ich sage ja:
Gott sei Dank, geht es mir gut
und ich habe nichts in der Richtung.
Deshalb kann ich es
nicht unbedingt nachvollziehen.
Du dachtest dann auch,
du müsstest mich eher pushen.
Genau, ein wenig jagen.
Dann durftest du mal zu
so einer Gesprächssitzung mitkommen,
zum Psychiater.
Dort konnte er seine Fragen stellen.
Der Psychiater meinte aber,
es wäre besser,
wenn er mich einfach machen liesse.
Ich würde selbst spüren,
wann ich was aushalten kann.
Wie viel geht.
Er soll mich einfach machen lassen.
Und nicht: "Komm jetzt, komm jetzt!"
Das war eigentlich kontraproduktiv.
Denn dann fühlte ich mich
erst recht unter Druck gesetzt,
und das war nicht gut.
Du.
Siehst du jetzt?
- Ja.
* Winseln *
Ja, ja.
Jetzt ist mal fertig gefressen, was?
Fertig gefressen. Ja.
Knallen.
- (Beide) Eins, zwei, drei.
Uh. Aufheben!
Das ging schnell bei dir.
Abrollen!
Aufdecken! Nein.
Nein, ich meine Aufnehmen.
Ah, haha! Da! Yes!
Ich wurde sehr schnell
damit konfrontiert,
weil sie es mir
von Anfang an erklärt hat.
So habe ich auch gelernt,
es zu verstehen
und damit umzugehen.
Wenn Mami nicht
in ein Einkaufszentrum gehen konnte,
gingen wir
z.B. in einen kleineren Laden.
Es gab auch sehr viele Sachen,
die zusammenspielten,
die nicht gingen.
Ich hätte es gemerkt, auch wenn sie
mir nichts gesagt hätte.
Denn es ist nicht normal,
dass eine Mutter nicht
in einen Bus einsteigt und so.
Aber ich sehe es nicht als
eine grosse Rolle, in meinem Leben.
Natürlich hat es mich "geprägt",
aber ich sehe es gar nicht
im negativen Sinn.
Das war immer das Letzte,
was sie wollte:
dass wir noch mehr darunter leiden,
wie sie sagen würde.
Das hat sie nie gemacht.
Sie hat uns nie
in schwierige Situationen einbezogen
oder als Stütze gebraucht.
Das wollte sie nie.
Ich sagte auch als Kind immer:
"Komm, Mami, gehen wir spazieren!"
Und sie sagte immer: "Nein, ich will
mich nicht auf dir abstützen."
Die Krankheit für mich zu ertragen,
ist eines.
Da habe ich das Gefühl,
ich könne das.
Ich kann mittlerweile damit leben.
Aber vor einem Kind, vor
meinen eigenen Kindern zu stehen,
und immer wieder sagen müssen:
"Es tut mir leid,
das kann ich nicht machen."
Und nachher die Kinder z.B.
mit Leuten weggehen zu sehen,
die das können,
z.B. meine Mutter oder Freunde,
die die Kinder mitgenommen haben ...
Diese Kinder weggehen zu sehen,
zurückzubleiben, und zu wissen,
dass sie das eigentlich
mit der Mutter machen wollten,
nicht mit irgendjemanden,
ist wirklich megatraurig.
Sie fragt auch immer,
ob es für mich schwierig ist,
dass ich gewisse Sachen
nicht mit ihr machen kann,
aber für mich ist das
nicht wirklich schwierig.
Ich sehe,
dass es für sie schwierig ist,
und das ist für mich das Schwierige,
um es so zu sagen.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich kann es anderweitig erleben.
Ich muss nicht mit meiner Mutter
erleben, was sie nicht kann.
Es fehlt mir nicht, dass ich nicht
in ein Einkaufszentrum gehen kann.
Ich werde immer vermissen,
dass ich mit meinen Kindern
nie weit spazieren konnte.
Ich habe immer
ein Bild von meinen Kindern,
wie ich mit meinen Kindern
wandern gehe, mit Rucksäcken,
und einen Tagesausflug mache.
Das konnte ich alles nie machen.
Das ist das, was für mich
am Ganzen das Schmerzhafteste ist.
Obwohl die Kinder
immer beschwichtigen:
"Es ist nicht so schlimm, Mami."
Aber für mich ist es schlimm.
Immer noch und immer wieder.
Angst ist oft unerträglich
und kann uns am Leben hindern.
Aus Angst vor Panikattacken
entwickeln viele Betroffene
Vermeidungsstrategien
und nehmen beispielsweise
wegen Tunnels grosse Umwege in Kauf.
Wenn die Lebensgestaltung
durch Ängste
allzu stark eingeschränkt wird,
ist eine Therapie notwendig.
* Monotone, düstere Klänge *
Ich habe gelernt, dass ich
diese Vermeidungstaktik meiden muss.
Also, dass ich sie ablegen muss.
Ich muss erst recht versuchen,
mich dem zu stellen.
Und dann, in einer Situation
wie z.B. einem Konzert,
mitten zwischen all den Leuten,
denkt man:
"Es ist ja gar nicht so schlimm."
Du hattest vorher viel mehr
Bedenken, als in diesen Moment.
So hatte ich wieder
viel mehr Vertrauen in mich selbst.
Ich kann wieder Lift fahren
ohne Probleme.
Ich fahre mit dem Auto durch Tunnels
oder auf Autobahnen.
Das sind alles Sachen,
die ich damals vermieden habe.
Aber ... Ausser dem Fliegen stresst
mich eigentlich nichts mehr so sehr.
(Frau) Also, wer ist dran?
(Frau) Zwei Pfefferminztees.
- Zum Hiertrinken?
Ja.
- Zweimal Tee.
Ich denke,
ich habe das gut überstanden.
Ich brauche keine Medikamente mehr.
Aber ganz weg ist es nicht.
Es klopft immer mal wieder
ein wenig an.
D.h. dann für mich,
vielleicht mal wieder
einen Gang zurückschalten,
wieder einmal
eine kleine Auszeit nehmen,
sich für den Moment wieder einmal
etwas mehr um sich selbst kümmern.
Nicht in diesem Hamsterrad bleiben
und sich dabei verrückt machen.
Ihr könnt das Kissen
unter den Kopf nehmen.
Die Beine gleich aufstützen.
Mir wurde jetzt
eine IV zugesprochen.
Ich finde, ich habe die
auch schon längst verdient.
Das ist ein Bericht, der klar sagt,
dass ich austherapiert bin.
Damit muss man
zuerst mal zurechtkommen.
Einerseits: "Aha, okay,
austherapiert, hoffnungslos."
Aber ich sage dir,
auf der anderen Seite
bin ich so froh über diesen Satz.
Ich habe therapeutisch
so ziemlich alles durchgemacht.
Ich habe noch eine Therapeutin,
aber sonst ...
Ich habe so keine Lust mehr
auf Therapien.
Ich habe ein paar
sehr gute, enge Freundinnen,
die die Thematik natürlich kennen.
Die mich nicht fragen:
"Kommst du morgen nach Zürich
ans AC/DC-Konzert?"
Die wissen, Claudia kommt nicht.
Claudia geht auch nicht
auf eine Seilbahn.
Claudia
kommt auch nicht 3 Std. spazieren.
Dann gehen wir halt zusammen essen,
wenn es irgendwie geht.
Oder sie kommen zu mir nach Hause.
Aber der Kontakt zu denen, die ich
habe, ist sehr eng und sehr gut.
Auch wenn ich mich beim Wunsch
ertappe, erste Klasse zu fahren,
Einkaufszentren grundsätzlich meide
und Türme und Gipfel
lieber gar nicht besteige,
leide ich nicht
an überbordenden Angstzuständen.
Trotzdem merke ich,
wie die Grenzen fliessend sind.
Die Frage, wo die Krankheit beginnt,
ist auch für Fachleute
nicht einfach zu beantworten,
und die Betroffenen
müssen sie sich selber stellen.
2008 war ich ja fast ein halbes Jahr
lang im Sanatorium Kilchberg.
Dann war ich für fast drei Jahre
krankgeschrieben.
Über die IV konnte ich eine Art
Wiedereingliederungsprogramm machen.
Anfänglich mit 50 % in
einer Stiftung, ohne Leistungsdruck.
Dort konnte ich
den Motor wieder hochfahren.
Ich hatte dann ein Abschlussgespräch
beim IV-Berater.
Der fand dann, ich würde das
nicht mehr zurückschaffen,
und bot mir eine 50-%-Rente an.
Ich erschrak ziemlich.
Ich fand,
das komme überhaupt nicht infrage.
"Ich will arbeiten gehen,
und zwar 100 %."
Ich ging dann
die ersten paar Monate stempeln
und konnte mich dann bei meinem
heutigen Arbeitgeber vorstellen.
Das war noch schwierig.
Ich konnte schlecht
"drei Jahre Sabbatical"
in meinen Lebenslauf schreiben
und war dort sehr offen.
Ich kann mich sehr gut
an das Gespräch
mit dem damaligen CEO erinnern.
Er hatte extrem viel Verständnis.
Er fand ...
... ihn interessiere nicht,
was vorher war,
sondern ihn interessiere
nur die Zukunft.
Er gab mir diese Chance.
Jetzt bin ich seit sieben Jahren
beim selben Arbeitgeber.
Es hilft sehr, dass ich
vom Arbeitgeber keinen Druck habe.
Die wissen auch,
was mit mir los ist.
(Lachend) Ich bin erfolgreich.
Sie setzen auf mich.
Sie halten an mir fest.
Das geniesse ich natürlich auch.
Was ich nie loswerde,
und das ist einfach so,
ist, dass diese Angst
quasi mein ständiger Begleiter ist.
Aber ich ...
Das war damals das Ziel der Therapie
und jetzt auch der letzten Jahre,
dass es darum geht, dass ich
einen adäquaten Umgang damit finde.
Dass ich es wie annehme. Sie ist
sozusagen mein Freund, diese Angst.
Es gibt dann bessere
und weniger gute Zeiten.
Wenn ich sage,
dass ich das quasi überwunden habe,
dann heisst das nicht, dass ich
nie mehr eine Panikattacke habe.
Weisst du, was ich
auf deinem Plan noch gesehen habe?
Am 6. Dezember
gehst du zum ersten Mal klettern.
Ja, ich weiss.
Ich hatte die Wahl
und habe sie immer noch,
entweder am Ganzen zu verzweifeln,
weil ich so vieles nicht kann,
was normale Menschen können.
Es gäbe genügend Grund,
zu verzweifeln und aufzugeben.
Aber im Ganzen gesehen
habe ich das Gefühl,
ist es nach wie vor
ein Schutz für mich.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob ich es
ohne diesen Schutz schaffen würde.
Mein Leben ist sehr klein.
In diesem kleinen Rahmen
kann ich leben,
kann meinen Alltag bewältigen.
Wenn es grösser wäre, bin ich
nicht sicher, ob ich es könnte.
Egal wie viel?
- Ja.
Je mehr, desto weicher
wird es eigentlich. - Aha.
Ja, super.
Wenn ich ...
... mal eine kleine Pause brauche,
wenn es mir vorne
doch ein wenig zu viel wird,
komme ich schnell
hier nach hinten ...
... trinke einen Kaffee
und mache ein paar Spiele.
So kann ich am besten
wieder runterkommen.
Das könnte ich stundenlang machen.
Das kann Kurt
überhaupt nicht verstehen.
Wenn wieder einmal ein Anflug
einer solchen Panikattacke kommt,
d.h., wenn es wieder enger wird
oder es von unten heraufkommt,
dann, habe ich gelernt,
kann ich das übers Atmen ...
Es gibt Atemtechniken,
die man lernen kann.
Man kann einfach ...
Mit ruhigem Durchatmen
kriegt man das wieder weg.
Das sind ein paar Sekunden,
in denen es wiederkommt.
Inzwischen ist es für mich ein
alter Bekannter. Er gehört zu mir.
Aber ich kann gut damit leben.
Es belastet mich nicht mehr.
* Langsame, nachdenkliche Musik *